how well does tiger remember his iconic
shot at the Masters what commentator
called the 16th hole what was your
overall score going into the 16th hole I
want to say I was 12 under amazing how
far away from the hole were you on that
second shot 60 feet or so how many
seconds did it take from oh God
a lifetime I think it's still rolling
how long did the ball sit on the rim of
the cup before too long way too long two
seconds what was Vern's iconic call on
TV in your life you heard of the same
thing like that
seen anything like that what was your
celebration after the bow Windows Steve
and I missed the high five I think three
times and finally we kind of
semi-connected I ended up doing some
kind of arm up in the air Stevie did his
right arm up in the air when the ball
gets to just before the hole when it was
about four or five feet out there's a
guy who must have had a perfect line
down the fault line she screamed I I've
always I can always remember him saying
it's in and he said it's in twice that's
when I spread it up onto the green and
then I get up on the green then the ball
stops and then it finally goes in